all right so Donald Trump spoke
yesterday in Miami Florida at a Hispanic
leadership conference called the afpi
Hispanic leadership conference if you
put Trump and Hispanic folks together
something weird is bound to happen and
this is one of the strangest speeches I
have ever seen Donald Trump give Beyond
bizarre super glitchy his skin almost
matching the red step and repeat behind
the lectern everything about it bizarre
I have never seen Trump's brain glitch
this badly here is the first uh example
Two glitches in one sentence Trump
trying to talk about during his
anti-trans rant saying without parental
consent he calls it parental consult and
then in trying to say he will oppose the
Biden Administration he says
administrating and every time it happens
he looks disoriented it's that
glitchiness and Trump does not look good
folks so teach you should ever be
allowed to teach transgender to our
children well parental for himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administrating at this this
Administration
the Biden administration's sick plan to
require yeah visibly disoriented and
then at another really strange moment
Donald Trump seemingly stumbling on what
the U.S population is confused about the
American population and kind of turns it
into a rant about immigration to try to
save himself and just really looking
confused up there we'll never be behind
China even though they have slightly
more people than we do like about a
billion more
they have 1.5 billion we have actually
our country is so crazy now we don't
even know how many we have we have any
idea because I believe the number of
people that came into our country and
will come in this year is 10 million
people not 3 million could even be 12
million people we have absolutely no
idea what it is so it's hard to say how
many people we have because we have no
idea how many people have come into our
country illegally
but we as you can hear this the crowd
sitting completely silently and I don't
know if that's the most interesting rant
to a group of Hispanic leaders at
another moment Donald Trump told a
completely Bonker story about how if he
ran against George Washington and
Abraham Lincoln he would defeat them by
40 percentage points in some
hypothetical time traveling election I
believe I remember a very famous
pollster very well-known John McLaughlin
came to my office just prior to the play
coming in he said sir if George
Washington and Abraham
Lincoln sir
came alive from the dead and they formed
a president vice president team you
would beat them by 40 percent
what did the brain statements okay I
mean it it's so dumb it's like you can't
even fact check something so stupid uh
and the idea that that's what a pollster
is telling him it's like you lost by a
record number of votes to Joe Biden who
as you claim ran a campaign from his
basement how embarrassing you're not
defeating George Washington and Lincoln
when you can't even beat Biden
campaigning from his basement give me a
break dude it doesn't make any sense
Trump then ranting about the Mar-A-Lago
raid and Trump says he's thinking as he
speaks here and that's a really
dangerous thing for Trump to do
you know they spend all their time on
nonsense the FBI nonsense raiding
Mar-A-Lago let's let's raid Mar-A-Lago
but leave the cartels alone how about
that
I think they think of this I'm just
thinking as I'm speaking
you don't mind if I go a little off
script but I think they raided
Mar-A-Lago but the cartels they they
have their own mar-a-lagos and those are
fine leave them alone let them continue
to destroy it's interesting likening
Mar-A-Lago as the physical center of a
crime family two cartels that that's
actually pretty fascinating and as as
you all know when Trump's on the
teleprompter it's a disaster because he
can't read it and then when he's off the
teleprompter doing the free association
it's bad because none of it makes any
sense whatsoever uh here's one more clip
where Trump says the raid at Mar-A-Lago
has given him a lot of free publicity
and what can they should be penalized
very severely for it the banks have let
the community down I think they've let
the country down Biden is not only
wrecking our economy he's destroying the
rule of law
you probably read and heard about the
document hoax has anyone heard about the
document hopes helicopters flying over
Mar-A-Lago
well they've given us about five billion
dollars worth of free publicity that's a
nice house
if it weren't so nice they probably
wouldn't be doing it because horribly
not as he says and then last clip here
just total stream of Consciousness
verbal inkblot
horrible because we'll make it
prosperous again because we don't take
our oil that's under our feet
Pamela right we don't take what's under
our feet I call it Liquid Gold we go to
them to get far inferior product that we
refine in the United States you know we
have the only refiners because what they
have is tar right it's very rough it's
not light and it's hard sweet it's rough
stuff and they talk about the
environment so they're going to
Venezuela to get stuff that's really bad
it's refined in the United States so if
there is anything goes in the air it
goes in the air in the United States
right but even if it went to another
country it blows over the whole thing is
so crazy yeah we don't even know what
you're talking about it's so crazy what
they're doing is so crazy so we're
begging Venezuela we're begging Saudi
Arabia we're begging everybody for oil
and we have more than everybody yeah
remember the truth of the matter is that
domestic oil production has actually
increased under Joe Biden from where it
was under Donald Trump slightly it's a
small margin the data is publicly
available and you can find it so really
not looking good is Trump here visible
confused and making very little sense
and the crowd seemingly recognizing it
sitting in complete and total silence I
often have a very hectic schedule and I
don't always have the time to plan the
exact nutrition of all of my meals but
our sponsor athletic greens just makes
it easy to make sure I'm getting the
nutrients I want I've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make ag-1 part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below